we're asked to solve for p and we have
the inequality here negative 3 p minus 7
is less than p plus 9. so what we really
want to do is isolate the p on one side
of this inequality and preferably the
left that just makes it a little bit
easier to read doesn't have to be but we
just want to isolate the p so a good
step to that is to get rid of this p on
the right hand side and the best way i
can think of doing that is subtracting p
from the right but of course if we want
to make sure that this inequality is
always going to be true if we do
anything to the right we also have to do
that to the left so we also have to
subtract p from the left
and so the left-hand side negative 3p
minus p that's negative 4p and then we
still have a minus 7 up here is going to
be less than p minus p those cancel out
it is less than nine
now the next thing i'm in the mood to do
is get rid of this negative seven or
this minus seven here so that we can
better isolate the p on the left hand
side so the best way i can think of to
get rid of a negative seven is to add
seven to it then it'll just cancel out
to zero so let's add seven to both sides
of this inequality
negative seven plus seven cancel out all
we're left with is negative four p on
the right hand side we have nine plus
seven is sixteen and it's still less
than
now the last step to isolate the p is to
get rid of this negative 4 coefficient
and the easiest way i can think of to
is to divide both sides by negative 4.
so if we divide this side by negative 4
these guys are going to cancel out we're
just going to be left with p we also
have to do it to the right hand side now
there's one thing that you really have
to remember since this is an inequality
this is not an equation if you're
dealing with an inequality and if you
multiply or divide both sides of the
equation by a negative number you have
to swap the inequality so in this case
the less than becomes greater than since
we're dividing by a negative number and
so negative 4 divided by negative 4
those cancel out
we have p
is greater than 16 divided by negative 4
which is negative 4. and we can plot
this solution set right over here and
then we can try out some values to help
us feel good about the idea of it
working
so let's say this is negative 5 negative
4 negative 3
negative 2
1 negative 1 i should say 0 let me write
that a little bit neater
negative 1
0 and then we can keep going to the
right and so our solution is p is not
greater than or equal so we have to
exclude negative 4. p is greater than
negative 4. so all the values above that
oh so negative 3.99999
will work negative 4 will not work and
let's just try some values out to feel
good that this is really the solution
set so first let's try out let's try out
when p is equal to negative 3. this
should work the way i've drawn it this
is in our solution set p equals negative
3 is greater than negative 4. so let's
try that out we have negative 3 times
negative 3.
this is the the first negative 3 is this
one and then we're saying p is negative
3 minus 7 should be less than instead of
a p we're going to put a negative 3
should be less than negative 3 plus 9.
negative 3 times negative 3 is 9 minus 7
should be less than negative 3 plus 9 is
6.
9 minus 7 is 2. 2 should be less than 6
of which of course it is now let's try a
value that definitely should not work so
let's try negative 5. negative 5 is not
in our solution set so it should not
work so we have negative 3 times
negative 5 minus 7. let's see whether it
is less than negative 5 plus 9.
negative 3 times negative 5 is 15 minus
7. it should really should not be less
than negative 5 plus 9.
so we're just seeing if p equals
negative 5 works 15 minus 15 minus 7
is 8
and so we get 8 is less than 4 which is
definitely this is definitely not the
case so p equals negative 5 doesn't work
and it shouldn't work because that's not
in our solution set and now if we want
to feel really good about it we can
actually try this boundary point
negative 4 should not work but it should
satisfy the related equation when i talk
about the related equation negative 4
should satisfy negative 3
minus 7 is equal to p plus 9. it'll
satisfy this but it won't satisfy this
because when we get 2 the same value on
both sides the same value is not less
than the same value so let's try it out
let's see whether negative 4 at least
satisfies the the related equation so if
we get negative 3 times negative 4 minus
7 this should be equal to negative 4
plus 9. so this is 12 minus 7 should be
equal to negative 4 plus 9 should be
equal to 5 and this of course is true 5
is equal to 5. so it satisfies the
related equation but it should not
satisfy this if you put negative 4 for p
here and i encourage you to do so
actually we could do it over here
instead of an equal sign
if you put it into the original
inequality let me delete all of that
it really just becomes this the original
inequality is this right over here if
you put negative 4 you have less than
less than and then you get 5 is less
than 5 which is not the case and that's
good because we did not include that in
the solution set we put an open circle
if negative 4 was included we would fill
that in but the only reason i would
include negative 4 is if this was
greater than or equal so it's good that
this does not work because 4 negative 4
is not part of our solution set you can
kind of view it as a boundary point